you've recently said that pranking your
mom on that crazy helicopter ride was
the most fun you've had shooting a video
except for one of the segments filmed
for this upcoming live show one how is
that helicopter ride that looked insane
but also without giving too much away
can you hint at what we could expect
from this new most fun segment well the
helicopter ride was it really was it was
an idea that I just go hey can we do
this like I talk to the people at the
helicopter school and then I was like
can I throw cameras in there and just
like go up with my mom and I just I mean
if came together so quickly and then
when they just said yes I I I had been
with this instructor before and he's you
know done that the crazy sh does in that
video and I was like man this would
definitely terrify my mother so it was a
dream that that I could make it come
together and then she was yeah it still
makes me laugh the how how scared she
was and how upset she was with me